we'll do what we do every friday what we
can't wait to see when sunday rolls
around
shireen i'll let you go first
well we got our first look at tua last
week and we're gonna get our second look
at two of this week
and is he going to be better than he was
last week mike he was not good he was 14
to 24 102 yards and a touchdown
the the dolphins won but they only won
because of their defense so he's 1-0
technically but he's got to play better
and you know when we
watched justin herbert his first start
and we watched
joe burrow and his first start we just
didn't see the struggles that
tua had against the rams i mean he
really struggled
and we just we we haven't seen that but
i don't know maybe it's that he hadn't
played in almost exactly a year
when he had that hip injury maybe it's
just getting some of the rust off
maybe he's not ready who knows but this
is about evaluation right i know you
wrote something about that earlier today
and the dolphins have to find out what
this guy has
yeah i don't know how much i agree with
the term audition that's something that
i think adam schefter reported that
it's an audition for tua for the rest of
the year brian flores the coach of the
dolphins bristled at that but the
reality
is you've got three types of teams in
the nfl teams that have
a clear-cut top-shelf franchise
quarterback teams that don't and are
looking for one
and teams that have a quarterback where
they don't they don't know
so with tua and the dolphins
they've got to accelerate the process
and find out
is he a potential or actual short-list
franchise quarterback
because if he's not and you don't see
him on that
path and the first round pick of the
houston texans that you hold by virtue
of the laramie tunzel kenny stills trade
could be in position where you may get a
shot at trevor lawrence or justin fields
or maybe you could package your own
first round pick to guarantee yourself
that spot
you've got to do the evaluation because
everybody wants that guy who's the
answer for the next 15 to 20 years
if you have a quarterback that you feel
good about for the next generation
that secures employment for a lot of
people because that means you're a
contender every year
you're going to win championships you're
going to be playing
big prime time games you're going to be
one of the teams that matter
if you have one of those handful of
great quarterbacks
so if it's not touah let's figure it out
because it could be trevor lawrence
or justin fields and and it's that
simple
and and there's no there's no offense or
insult to tua if the team does that if
i'm a dolphins fan i want them to do it
because i don't want them to keep the
wrong guy when the right guy
could have been had all right i can't
wait to see whether or not the tennessee
titans who have now lost two in a row
after being one of the best teams in the
nfl
can they muster a pass rush against a
team that has an offensive line
that stinks last week the bengals had 80
turnover in their starting offensive
line and they neutralized the tennessee
titans pass rush
this week they've cut vic beasley who
had done nothing
jamie and clowney may or may not play
with a knee
injury now he doesn't have any sacks but
he is a master of the f up the play stat
as chris calls it
but the titans got no sacks last week
they've got
seven and seven games they've got to get
to nick foles they've got to disrupt
nick foles because if nick foles has
time
he's going to make things happen that's
the big reason why
foles hasn't been special this year he's
got to throw the ball before he wants to
throw the ball
so you have inaccurate passes because he
has to make quicker decisions
and quicker commitments and it's been
harder for the bears
to operate their passing game so the
titans hey who
one of these team's gonna be on a
three-game losing streak and the titans
can't afford to have that happen not
after they started five and oh shireen
no they really can't mike and and i want
to see more from clowney and i know
chris loves clowney but let's face it
he had three sacks last year he's got
none this year he has six quarterback
hits
he's not lived up to really what the
titans expected when they brought him in
he's never had a double d digit sax
season i know he's really good against a
run
but i have watched many titans games
this year from start to finish
and there are just games with that you
go that you go was clowning even on the
field because i didn't see him
and i know he had he's had some injuries
some nagging injuries now he's got the
knee is he going to play is he not going
to play he's going to be game time
decision all that sort of stuff
but this is a team now with three
outside linebackers on its active roster
they really need him to play
and they really need him to play well
this week
all right what's next on your list
shereen
well i want to see when we finish this
tampa bay new orleans game
who holds the all-time passing
touchdowns record
is it going to be drew brees or is it
going to be tom brady
tom brady currently has 561 he passed
through
uh breeze on sunday who now has 560 and
they just keep swapping this record back
and forth mike
and it's a fun record and i think
whoever plays longest obviously is going
to end up with it breeze is 41. he's got
13 touchdowns this season
brady's 43. he's got 20 touchdowns this
season
which one's going to end up with the
record if i'm betting mike i'm putting
my money
on tom brady to hold it after this week
and i'm putting my
money on tom brady to hold it after both
of their careers are over
well yeah because he's going to play
next year and drew brees very well may
not and i think however long drew brees
plays braz brady's going to find at
least one more season so he definitely
has that record but it's amazing 1121
touchdown passes combined and we get to
see that
play out on sunday night football i want
to see in that same game how
will the saints go about defending all
of these tampa bay
weapons you can't double everyone and
that's one of the things mike evans said
on the way off the field
monday night to lisa salters of espn
after the tampa bay buccaneers
came back and beat the giants and then
held on at the end antonio brown is
going to take away some of the double
teams from me
so is that going to unlock mike evans is
that going to make him better
is the ball going to go his way more
will he be doubled that
this is a hell of a chess match for
dennis allen did he just go ahead and
commit
to doubling antonio brown or does he
wait until it's clear that brown
really is the guy that ripped up the
saints defense two years ago for 185
yards
what do they do about gronk did they put
a safety on him is that what malcolm
jenkins handles do they have linebackers
what do they do
so you've got gronk mike evans antonio
brown
chris goblin scotty miller you got to
worry about all those guys you got to
worry about getting dashed in the
running game if you over commit to the
pass
i can't wait to see how that defense
formally is constructed by dennis allen
the one guy i wouldn't want to be this
week mike is dennis allen the aggie
great is
has his hands full and i'm sure he's
ready for sunday to get here to figure
out
what they do but it's going to be a very
very difficult task for them
the game the one of the games i'm most
looking forward to is
how everson griffin is going to do
against the minnesota vikings and he and
mike zimmer you alluded to it earlier
have had this back and forth
and mike zimmer intended to complement
everson griffin when he said he was a
really good player here he was with mike
zimmer for six years in minnesota 10
years total
third all-time on the team in sacks but
everson griffith took that as a slight
that that he didn't call him great mike
zimmer only called him good he said i
think he's a great coach
not a good coach but i have something to
show them
players use all kinds of things for
motivation if this motivates everson
griffin great
he's got two and a half sacks this
season they came with the cowboys we'll
see what he can do
with the lions against his former team
but he's certainly going to be motivated
judging on his comments
and this is his debut with the lions
because of the covet 19 protocols even
though the trade came well over a week
ago he couldn't play last weekend when
the lions faced the colts
and yeah i think that this is everson
griffin
looking for anything he can to muster
extra motivation and that's fine the
michael jordan documentary
revealed that great players
will stretch embellish and even lie to
themselves if they have to they'll make
up indignities that never occurred to
get themselves
appropriately lathered up to go do what
they have to do but
that's going to be a great subplot to
this game
and as we discussed earlier i firmly
believe the loser of this game
is done can jake
lewton get it done or is it luke
jayton i really don't know i wrote down
here luke jayton as a joke but then i'm
thinking is that the joker is that the
serious name it is jake lewton
sixth round pick second straight sixth
round pick
of the jaguars and last year's gardner
minshew
turned out to be pretty good although
this year they're not winning football
games
minchu's got a thumb injury he's not
going to play and instead of going with
mike glennon
it's jake lewton who gets the call and
we'll see what he can do
against deshaun watson and company you
know every once in a while
you roll the dice on one of these guys
no one's ever heard of except people who
were fans of their college team
and uh it works there's a ben dinucci
that didn't work
maybe jake lewton will work for the
jacksonville jaguars
and save some jobs down there because
what a stunning fall
week one they beat the colts and they
haven't won a game
since shireen yeah including a loss to
the texans and now they play the texans
again
and gardner menchu is now seven and 12.
we were talking of him highly after week
one we're not talking about him so
highly now so
going to be interesting for the jaguars
but you figure they probably will get
one of those top two spots and get to
draft a quarterback
mike another game i'm looking at i want
to know which steelers defensive player
is going to be player of the week this
week
we've seen it a couple times so far this
uh this year
tj watts won it and stefan tuitt won it
this past
week minka fitzpatrick could have won it
tyson olualu could have won it cameron
hayward could have won it
i think one of those guys will win it
this week against the injury-depleted
cowboys
offensive line against the cowboys
depleted quarterbacks
uh no matter who they start they're
gonna have a rough day and that steelers
defense is really gonna take advantage
yeah it does seem like every week
there's another guy who steps up it's
just one of the benefits of having an
awesome defense like the steelers have i
want to see whether or not the chargers
will blow another 17 point lead they've
done it three times in the last four
games
it does not bode well for anthony lynn
the head coach of the team a guy i have
a ton of respect for but when you've got
justin herbert and it's clear he's the
real deal
this is an opportunity to go out and
attract a great coach to come to la and
run that chargers organization
and and attach his wagon to justin
herbert for the next
five 10 15 years however long herbert is
there i really do think if they put the
right pieces in place
with that chargers organization they can
emerge as the preeminent team
in la i think herbert's better than
jared goff
maybe not immediately but maybe maybe i
think i'd take herbert over golf right
now who would you take between the two
right now
herbert i would take herbert i think
he's been i think he's been better than
joe burrow frankly
yeah they just don't have the wins and
one of the reasons they don't have the
wins
herbert builds the leads and the defense
fails
to hold the lead hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports